gilbert bejjani il est président de
l'association belge des syndicats
médicaux
bonsoir et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france étendre le passé à
lithaire aux plus de 16 ans c'était
indispensable selon vous
oui mais pas dans tout le pays donc
d'abord vous voyez que c'est à l'hôpital
n'est pas pour du tout pour des raisons
de kobe de 7 pour d'autres soucis de
santé
le merci le en étant le pass là où le
taux de vaccination est faible et donc
j'entendais tout à l'heure ce qui se
passait en russie et certains qui disent
que ne pas se faire vacciner est quelque
chose qui est reprochable en effet le
vaccin protège mais à partir du moment
où le vaccin n'est pas obligatoire on
laisse quelque part le choix ça veut
dire you d'installation à la vaccination
qui va être bien accueillie par un parmi
la population la fonctionnaire
oui ça va fonctionner ce n'est pas du
tout une incitation au vaccin c'est un
complément à la gestion de la
transmission
puisqu'en fait le port du masque est
aussi obligatoire pour le dire de façon
simple dans les deux régions bruxelles
et la wallonie ou donc en francophonie
colombie où le taux de vaccination est
faible puisqu'il est de 80% pour les
plus que 18 ans en eau à l'oni il est de
90% et au delà de 90 en flandre alors
qu'il n'est que 2 66% à bruxelles donc à
partir du moment où le pauvre
vaccination est faible de la vaccination
qui protège n'est pas obligatoire on
demande aux personnes à bruxelles en
wallonie de garder le masque dans la
plupart des endroits votre fréquentation
où il ya un attroupement et on rajoute
en plus une obligation du collège ticket
pour les grands rassemblements et
certaines activités
autorisant de ce fait le retrait du
masque alors vous comprendrez aisément
que dans les restaurants où on retire
son masque pour m'en vais le coc vite
safetykey devient obligatoire à
bruxelles à partir de ce jour puisque de
fait on ne peut pas garder son masque
sur la bouche on donne un choix à la
population
qui n'a pas plu n'a pas su être
convaincu de la nécessité d'être
vaccinées en flandre on qui représente
comme un peu plus que la moitié de la
population belge est à plus que 80 11 %
de vaccination le port du masque n'est
plus obligatoire sauce en certains
endroits comme donc les institutions de
soins et le cowitz expliqué nous
demander que pour des très très grand
rassemblement pour justement simplement
pouvoir les autoriser comment est-ce que
vous expliquer ces différences de toute
vaccination vous parliez de la wallonie
de la flandre où il est plutôt il est
plutôt important contrairement à
bruxelles
mais les français ne connaissent pas ce
problème puisqu'il ya un chef d'état et
un ministre de la santé en belgique
comme vous savez on a trois régions et
trois communautés mais également neuf
ministres de la santé et donc la
prévention ce qui inclut la gestion des
cheveux la vaccination dépend en fait
des régions et les communautés et donc à
bruxelles il ya une autre stratégie aux
élus que les autres alors il ya aussi
des populations différentes officielle
est une petite île à très haute
concentration
par rapport aux autres régions de
population avec une population plus
jeune probablement un peu plus
réfractaires à la vaccination qui ne
comprend peut-être pas toujours
l'utilité mais aussi avec une population
de différentes origines
et donc il faut que le message passe à
tout le monde il ya eu beaucoup
d'efforts qui sont faits pour pouvoir
expliquer à tout un chacun selon comme
on dit son niveau de compréhension du
risque et des soins et de la maladie et
ce travail il est en cours je pense que
le taux augmentera mais donc voilà ce
sont des différences donc
d'organisations politiques mais aussi
deux populations différentes qui
explique cesser ces différences merci
beaucoup pour tout ces précise gilbert
bejjani merci pour votre intervention je
rappelle que vous êtes sûr au président
de l'association belge des syndicats
médicaux